the awakening I believe is the 1150
second film in which a ghostly kid and
have it's a school of some kind starring
a beautiful woman with long black hair
that can probably get wet very well and
look all creepy as it's all wet across
her face you just don't get many of
these type of movies anymore The
Awakening stars Rebecca Hall and Dominic
West and I kind of joked about the plot
a little bit in the intro and yes it's
very cliched this idea of this school
and there's a ghostly kid in there and
all these kids are terrified he's
showing up in pictures and he's making
weird faces in photos that people are
taking takes place in 1921 Rebecca Hall
plays a paranormal ghost investigator of
some kind she's probably one of the
first types of that career and she gets
sent to this school to investigate
what's going on because these kids are
terrified as Dominic West character
states who is a school teacher there
the kids are no longer afraid of bumps
in the night they are terrified for
their lives
this kids walking around the hallways
with this deformed look on his face kids
are seeing that adults are seeing it and
it's terrifying them obviously now
Rebecca Hall is this character who
studies these ghostly appearances she is
interested in learning about them but
she doesn't really believe in the
afterlife or have any thoughts that she
actually will ever encounter something
real this reminds me a lot of John
Cusack's character in 1408 which was
adapted from a Stephen King short story
he was a guy who investigated paranormal
things and he didn't really believe any
of it either and throughout his
experiences in the movie he starts to
believe certain things that he never
really thought were ever true really
enjoyed that movie the awakening took a
lot from the 1408 idea of that character
but it's a completely different film in
some ways a very good film and in some
ways no not so much Rebecca Hall was
really good in this movie you may
remember her from the town she brings
this really great quality to her
character that brings realism but also a
really good sense of authority I really
liked her in this movie I thought she
did a really nice job Dominic West plays
this schoolteacher who helps her come to
this school and then he's sort of like a
guiding support throughout taking her
through hallways and showing her this
and showing her that but as the film
concluded I kind of felt like his
character was pointless and not even
really necessary for the film I don't
really understand why his character
actually needs to be there I get that he
is a man and she's a woman and that's a
possibility for romantic in
and that's really all that I can really
understand also his character has a
stutter it seems like a pointless thing
his character has it isn't really
necessary to the movie and I don't
really like that when actors or writers
decided no what we're going to give this
guy a limp it always just seems like a
ploy to make us feel sorry for that
character for no real reason certain
scares in this movie worked really well
I like the idea that it was set in 1921
the countryside of England looks really
beautiful some of the scares and
suspense was actually pretty palpable
and I was surprised by that Rebecca Hall
was great in the movie some of the
performances are really good but really
where this movie fails is the ending and
I won't spoil anything for you but it is
an ending that when you see it you're
like okay I can kind of understand where
they're going and then you look back on
the movie and you're like that makes so
many things weird that makes everything
like different now there's so many
unanswered questions see there are
certain things in the ending that I like
that makes sense that okay I get it but
then there were certain things like this
in your face like look I know you're not
going to get this so we're just gonna
like show you everything that happened
in the movie it's an ending where when
things start to happen it's like they
just start showing you shots of what
already happened in the movie to remind
you of what you should already know but
it was like yes I I remember seeing all
that you don't have to remind me of all
that through a flashback the ending of
the film is interesting and ambitious
but it caused too many unanswered
questions to the beginning of the movie
that made it kind of hard to understand
some of the things that happen in the
movie that being said up until then that
was a very creepy movie I was interested
in the story there was a surprising
amount of depth in the characters that
you don't normally get in a horror film
like this and you could tell that Nick
Murphy the director was trying to tell a
more character-based story a more
character-driven story which is rare in
a horror film and I liked how Rebecca
Hall played her character I thought she
was really good in the movie and she was
definitely the standout of this film
overall it's just it's an interesting
movie like you get into it but then the
ending is kind of a bit of a letdown but
the fact that I enjoyed almost the
entire movie and I can't really deny
that I'm going to give the awakening a
b-minus
if you were to read box.this or Netflix
it you'd probably find more enjoyment
out of it I wouldn't really recommend
seeing this in theaters but I think if
you are a fan of horror films like me if
you just want to pick this up on DVD or
maybe through the Netflix or Redbox as I
said you'll probably find more enjoyment
out of it I also have a bit of an
announcement for you guys I'm
not sure how many of you may know this
you're following me on Facebook which
you should do because I give lots of
updates there and I also do polls for
you guys to choose like what films you'd
want me to see or review facebook.com
slash Chris Tuchman that simple also on
twitter my handle is Chris underscore
stuckman very simple all these links I'm
going to put in the description if
you're following me there you know that
I've started writing for a great website
called movie Dexcom and I really enjoy
writing it's actually how I started and
I've always wanted to get back into it
so I started writing some reviews for
this great website and if you want to
read more of my written reviews you can
go to movie Dexcom I'm going to be doing
that regularly now it's a lot of fun I'm
not going to be doing as many written
reviews as I do video reviews but it's a
lot of fun for me it's a different
medium to express my thoughts on movies
and I enjoy it a lot so if you guys
would like to check that out sometime
more than welcome to
as always guys if you'd like this review
you can subscribe to my channel and get
stuck mine eyes